The David Pakman Show is mostly funded by
members who sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
I will not waste any more time talking about
it because we have such a busy agenda.
But I invite you to grab a membership at Join
Pakman dot com where you can also read about
all the great membership benefits.
OK, up hatriot mail has become managing the
hate mail we have been getting since Joe Biden
won the election on November 3rd, November
7th, as it was called by the media.
It's almost a job in and of itself.
The hate mail has so scaled up.
And I have one such example for you today.
But first, a quick reminder.
What is hatriot mail exactly?
Last time I checked, this was America.
And I have the right to share my droplets
with whoever I want.
Hatriot mail written by patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because freedom.
Right, so hatriot male is one, a professional
voiceover artist does interpretive readings
of the hate mail that I get and hear is, you
know, we don't we could do five shows a week
of just an hour of hate mail at this point.
We really could.
But here is just one example for you to take
a listen to.
David Pakman is a frustrated loser.
The show is circling the drain.
Million subscribers, 50 million views per
month.
Oh, how much did you pay?
So, blad, almost two years later.
And David is more kux than ever.
Sore loser.
Yes.
You lost spell loser with a DVD.
You are a shill and a fraud.
Keep it up.
I love those credentials.
You know, I learned some stuff from the hey,
I didn't realize that we had 50 million views
in a 30 day period, but we actually did, which
is insane.
And I appreciate this hatriot for for for
letting me know about these stunning numbers.
I love it.
The part that's confusing to me is what is
we lost?
I mean, like what exactly what what did we
lose?
Joe Biden won.
Right.
And I got into an interesting Facebook exchange
yesterday against my better judgment with
some friends, with a couple people, not my
friends.
But there are people in the thread who believe
that Trump will be sworn in for a second term
on January 20th.
And here's my question to you.
Should we be betting these people money?
And what I mean is I'm not a betting man.
I don't really bet.
But it seems as though there's money to be
made betting money against the people who
say Trump will be sworn in on January 20th.
If they really believe that, I bet one hundred
dollars, I'd bet a thousand dollars.
I'd even look at betting more.
But I heard from people who tried this with
family members and they said that the family
members eventually backed out, typically coming
up with some excuse, like, well, listen, it's
all rigged.
Like if if it weren't rigged, Trump would
be getting sworn in.
So I'm no longer participating in the bet,
which is, of course, the point of the bet.
The point of the bet is, will Trump be sworn
in not would Trump be sworn in if.
Right.
As I said before, if my grandmother had wheels
instead of legs, she would be a bicycle.
It's not.
Well, Trump would have been sworn in were
it not, quote, rigged.
The bet is, will he be sworn in?
That seems like easy money to me, but maybe
it's taking advantage of people who can't
even think straight.
Let me know what your thoughts are.
And remember that the way to fight patriotism
in your community is to use the coupon code
hatriot forty when you get a membership.
This is a code that has been often used, much
imitated, never equaled.
Hatriot forty saves you forty percent.
Join Pakman Dotcom and it's spelled HKT are
Iot for zero.